[Music]
welcome back guys goes on here for anime
uproar today I'm going to tell you
everything you need to know about one of
the most important Titans in attack on
Titan the smiling Titan the Titan that
appeared at the beginning of the show
and change lives of our main characters
forever the smiling Titan a Terrans our
protagonists own mother before his eyes
and sparked his thirst for revenge which
has for the most part driven the story
ever since before we get into it I want
to thank you guys for the unbelievable
support you have shown dear God these
last few weeks have been insane and so
thanks you guys and of course girls who
have been liking and commenting on these
videos it really means a lot and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe because we have plenty of
attack on Titan videos on this channel
and many more on the way as always in
order to explain the smiling Titan its
identity and everything else you need to
know about it I will need to draw on the
manga so beyond this point there will be
among us spoilers proceed with extreme
caution be prepared to get your mind
blown all right if you're still with me
and psyched to get going smash that like
button and let's get into it
Detroit entity was smiling Titan is
Deena Jaeger formerly known as Deena
Fritz she's the first wife of Gregor
Erin's father and the mother of Zeke
Jaeger Aaron's half-brother and the
current possessor of the Beast Titan so
yeah she's kind of a big deal yes she is
a small woman with a petite frame even
though she is relatively short
she has large eyes she has fair skin and
blonde hair she usually has a worried
expression on her face in contrast to
her human form her time form is
constantly grinning a big wide smile
which is why we call it the smiling
Titan the Titan is also quite large
despite deena stature this is probably
due to the fact that she has royal blood
Zeke is 17 metres tall in his Titan form
as opposed to Aaron and Reiner who are
15 metres tall in addition when rod
Reese who also has royal blood became a
Titan he became a previously unseen 120
metres tall Titan he was so big in fact
that he couldn't even stand up without
the support of the wall so it does seem
like royal blood does usually
meaning that you're going to be an
above-average sides Titan now that we
have the basics out of the way let's get
into some history about a hundred years
ago the king of the LDN Empire fled the
main continent because he wanted peace
and move his capital to the island of
paradise this king is known as 145th
king or the first king of the walls
he had the coordinate or the power of
the founding Titan if you want to learn
everything you need to know about this
power make sure to check out Mike worden
explained video among other things the
coordinate allowed him to control Titans
this power was what kept the LD an
empire intact but after he left Marlay
with the other LD ends now called island
dwellers Marlay took over using the
constant feuding of the remaining LD and
houses to their advantage in this way
marley took control of seven of the nine
titan powers which they used to maintain
order meanwhile the first can use the
founding titan power which could only be
used with full capacity by members of
the royal family to create the three
walls by using tens of millions of
colossus titans
and their hardening abilities however he
abandoned all the LD ins outside of the
walls now living in the Marlay
controlled continent this is where we
get to Deena Deena Fritz was a member of
the royal family but she belongs to a
branch that didn't want to abandon the
LD n people in DL Dean cause in Marlay
she along with her family kept her
identity secret and lived in the lab
areal internment camp there they waited
in hiding hoping that the LD ins would
regain power and their true status would
be recognized once more it is the owl
also known as Ehren Kruger who sends
Deena to the LD and restorationist where
she meets and falls in love with Grisha
Yeager she is the one that explains to
the restorationist
how the founding titan was taken by the
first king two parodies she also
explains that the founding titan power
is the key that will allow that to
control all the other Titans and restore
LD and rule she says that the first king
retreated behind the walls because he
refused to fight anymore this is when
Grisha declares that they will reclaim
the founding Titan and restore the true
LD in monarchy the one that stayed and
didn't abandon their people Deena is so
touched by his words that she hugs him
and begins to cry
arms a year later Grisha and Deena get
married and have a child they named Zeke
it is clear that Deena loves the child
very much and both her and Grisha see
this royal blooded baby as the key to
restoring el dia they finally get their
chance when the Marlon government brings
about a new program so that they can
finally infiltrate parodies not only is
the power of the signing time waiting
behind king Fritz's walls but the island
itself has many resources that the
Malayan government knows that don't need
in the future they realize that
technology is quickly progressing and
that the power of the Titans will not be
absolute for long since the Malayan
government needs Albion to use the 7
Titan powers that they have in their
possessions they decide to recruit ldm
children who are between five and seven
years old in order to incentivize the LD
and people to cooperate the government
proclaims that the chosen warriors and
their families will get honorary Marlin
citizenship which would mean a better
standard of living and hopefully less
unwarranted cruelty and violence Grisha
and Deena see this as an opportunity for
the algae and restorationist and agreed
to play Zeek into the government program
so that he can be an LDN spy however to
their surprise the boy betrays his
parents Deena along with Grisha is sent
to the island of paradise as punishment
where Aldean's are injected with a titin
serum and turned into mindless
man-eating Titans were doomed to roam
the island for eternity
or at least until they are killed by
captain Levi Deena is brought next to
Grisha before she is injected with the
titan serum and pushed off the sea wall
she tells him not to worry and that no
matter what she becomes she will find
him Richard tries to tell everyone that
she's of royal blood and should not be
killed
he knows that LD ends with royal blood
are very valuable to the Marlins because
once acquired they can control the
fating titan power but the owl who is
revealed to be airing Krueger shuts him
up Aaron later tells him that becoming a
mindless Titan is probably preferable to
the marlane government forcing her to
bear children to inherit the founding
titan power for the rest of her life
then sergeant major gross a very fitting
name injects Adina with a titin serum
and she is thrown off the sea wall as a
traumatized and horrified Grisha watches
his wife get turned into this
Eiling tighten this is also the first
time that we as readers realized that
the smiling Titan who killed Aaron's
mother and started him down the path of
revenge was actually grisha's first
wife's and insane twist indeed and this
is why some people have said that the
smiling Titan killed Aaron's mother out
of revenge because she married her
husband but this is unlikely because she
is in a mindless state and she wouldn't
actually have a way of knowing that
Grisha who's absent at this point Mary
Carla Aaron's mother nevertheless it is
quite the coincidence in addition to
showing up after the Colossus Titan
breaches
she got Sheena district in wall Maria
Dina's Titan also shows up five years
later when Reiner along with vessels is
attempting to kidnap Aaron and a mirror
after
urlan and Mekas a rescue Aaron and begin
to retreat the armored Titan starts
throwing Titans at them which causes
Mikasa and Aaron to fall Hannes tries to
pay is that to the Yeager family by
killing a smiling Titan and saving Eren
and Mikasa but he is killed in the
process and devoured by the smiling
Titan the smiling Titan that reaches out
for Aaron who punches his hand this
activates the power of the coordinate or
founding Titan power within Aaron among
other things the founding Titan allows
the possessor to control Titan after
making contact with vinas Titan suddenly
Eren is able to control the surrounding
Titans and sends them to kill Deana
the only reason Aaron is finally able to
activate the dormant power of the
founding Titan inside him is because
Dena is a royal blood
the Titans rip her to shreds and devour
her and thus the deaths of his mother
and Hannes are finally avenged
however Aaron Sweet Revenge does not
turn out to be as satisfying as he
expected especially after we find out
that Titans aren't actually evil they
are members of the same LDN race who
have been turned into man-eating Titans
against their wills and are now
suffering through an endless nightmare
as amir called it as you can see Dena
Fritz turns out to be one of the most
important characters in attack on Titan
she is grisha's first wife who brings
the LD and restorationist important
historical documents and knowledge of
the founding Titan she gives birth to
Zeek who went on to become the strongest
Titan shifter and
one of the major antagonists of the show
if you want to know more about Zeke and
the beast Titan be sure to check out the
beast Titan explained video and also our
friend Knox tacos video where he goes
into why the Beast Titan is such a great
villain
Dinah's Titan also eats our protagonists
mother which sparks Erin's thirst for
revenge she brings out Aaron's dormant
powers and indirectly helps our
protagonist get to the truth behind the
Titans in the world outside the walls
Deana first is importance in the world
of attack on Titan cannot be denied
anyways guys there it is everything you
need to know about the smiling Titan aka
Dina Fritz thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to smash that like button and
tell me what you think about Dina and
her character in the comments section
below
as always feel free to make suggestions
for future videos in the comment section
and if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe for more attack on Titan
videos I want to take a moment to thank
our patrons shot off a lovely tsundere
Gilgamesh third strikes a NATO Christian
floor
Urbano for never 9/15 AKA girl bro AMS
and original ink thank you guys so much
for helping to make all this possible if
you also want to see more videos like
this one consider supporting us on
patreon link in the description and as
always until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]